Oh, my gosh, knitting and Intarsia is so
easy with the TH-160. What's in Intarsia ?
It allows you to knit blocks of color
across the row at the same time,
without any floats across the back.
The manual makes this seem really
complicated, but it's not.
Let's get started.
Start by knitting a few
rows in plain knitting.
Just get some stitches on the machine
with your main color.
End with the carriage on the right and all
needles are in "B", or working position.
Un-hread the working yarn and just
kind of hold it out of the way.
Set the carriage to PART and pass
the carriage to the left.
Remember, with the PART setting
and the needles in "B" position,
you can safely free past the carriage.
Next position, the needles for in Intarsia.
Still no yarn in the carriage.
Move the change lever to Intarsia
and pass the carriage to the right.
This time all the needles are aligned in
"D" position and the latches are open.
The carriage is on the right.
Put your working ball of yarn on the floor
in front of you and line up the other
colors you'll be using. You'll need
an end of yarn for each color.
I'm going to knit three
colors across the row.
I'm sure you will get much
more creative with this.
But for now, let's keep things simple.
First place the working yarn
over the first group of needles.
Just lay it on the needles
from right to left.
Lay the second yarn across
the next set of needles.
Make sure the tail of the yarn is
on the right and the working end is
always going to be away from the carriage.
Lay the third yarn across the last set
of needles. Again, make sure
that tail is on the right.
Don't secure the yarns,
just loosely hold them in your left hand
and pass the carriage to the left.
You'll feel the yarn being fed
into the carriage as the stitches knit.
Now, don't hold too tight.
Your left hand is now
replacing the tension mast.
Voila.
We've knit all three colors in the row
with one pass of the carriage.
The next step is important.
To prevent holes, you need to make sure
that you cross the yarns as you
position them for the next row.
Lay the blue strand across
the left group of needles.
Pick up and lay that pink strand
across the center group of needles.
Notice that the two yarns cross.
Then lay the green across
the first set of needles.
Holding the three strands
loosely, knit across the row.
One more time
with the carriage on the right,
lay the green yarn across
the first group of needles.
Make sure those yarns cross.
Pick up that pink yarn and lay it across
the next group. Cross the yarns and lay
the blue yarn across the needles.
And knit across.
The change lever stays in Intarsia
for the whole process.
Because we made sure those yarns crossed,
you can see that the join between
the two colors is secure.
There aren't any holes
I'll need to work in all these yarn tails.
But can you see the possibilities
of this in Intarsia technique?